the freedom to do activities that an
individual wants to engage in how does
holding up internet poker affect them
and their rights that's a great question
for a philosopher-king unfortunately we
don't live in a philosophy kingdom we
live in a political world poker players
who enjoy playing online are often
forced onto sketchy offshore websites
because of restrictive federal
legislation that makes it extremely
difficult to place bets over the
internet but a new push to legalize
online gaming in California could begin
to change all that and with some polls
showing overwhelming support for
licensing and regulation of online poker
to help patch up the states busted
budget passing Stateville 1463 might
seem like a no-brainer but in California
nothing's ever a no-brainer the
obstacles in California in from my
perspective or one that our political
mostly Steve Miller is an entrepreneur
business professor and tournament poker
player who's been on the front lines of
the political battle over online poker
for years he says that anti-gambling
moralists like Alabama Republican
Spencer Bachus who once called online
play the crack cocaine of gambling no
longer have much influence on the debate
that's actually pro gambling special
interests looking to hold on to
lucrative deals who are the biggest
obstacles along the road to legalization
the issue of tribal gaming interest in
California is certainly most difficult
issue to deal with right now I don't
think that they should have the sole
monopoly on online poker in the state of
California tries weren't borns it is
we fought for this david keene tanya is
a lobbyist for the California tribal
business alliance which opposes any
online poker legalization that doesn't
maintain a monopoly on gaming for the
tribes if you've seen the tribal
reservation you understand that they're
not places they picked there are places
they were sent so what kind of economic
development can you have in a place
which is so desolate so the only thing
that the tribes found which could create
economic development was something they
could do that the other folks couldn't
do to cut them off and that was gaming
Miller who's done lobbying of his own on
behalf of the pro poker groups says that
legislators aren't likely to meet the
tribes demands legislators were willing
to share that pot but they weren't
willing at the time to grant a monopoly
operating interest to the tribal
interests what the tribes want is it's
definitely serve their self-interest but
I don't think it serves the interests of
the players the interests of people who
just want to play poker online appears
to be the last thing on anyone's mind
existing gaming operators are simply
trying to hold on to their lucrative
state granted monopoly for as long as
possible you have to fight it as long as
you can why speed up the inevitability
right put it off as long as you can i'm
going to die someday but i'm not going
to sit back and let it happen right i'm
gonna meet well and work out try to keep
this baby going as long as possible it's
not the government's role to determine
what we should who should not be doing
given that there's an outlet to do it
it's a game it's a game that a lot of us
have played for a lifetime we'd like to
continue that playing that game using
the technology that exists but contango
says that unless the government can
prove that legalization won't have a
negative effect on the tribes the bill
is going nowhere until we can clearly
get our arms around the impact that this
will have upon our existing brick and
mortar facilities there's no way that we
can do something which might be the
death knell for our industry state
initiatives are only one part of the
puzzle for online poker which is
regulated on the federal level by the
2005 you
act which instructed financial
institutions to block transactions
related to unlawful internet gambling he
was an ambiguous law he didn't really
define what unlawful internet gambling
was it was bad legislation and in my
mind it shouldn't Department the vague
regulations surrounding online gambling
have led most financial institutions to
avoid the business altogether leading
many poker players to use less secure
offshore sites online poker play will
continue I mean it is available now it's
available from sources from operators
who aren't licensed you may not be
reputable who may not be offering a fair
game we don't provide proper consumer
protection to the players until online
poker or regulation is reformed to both
at state and federal levels online
players might just be out of luck